Christmas is coming but Goodwill will be
in short supply on the railways the rmt
union announcing a new round of strikes
and blaming Government after two weeks
of negotiations ended with no new offer
being made to its members it's
impossible to find a negotiated
settlement when the Dead Hand of the
government is presiding over and
blocking a resolution I'm not the Grinch
I'm a trade Union official and I'm
determined to get a deal
the rmt is scheduled for 48-hour strikes
on the 13th and 14th and 16th and 17th
of December a busy shopping and getaway
weekend and on January the 3rd and 4th
and the 6th and 7th there's also an
overtime ban from December the 18th to
January the second that will impact
planned maintenance the unions has a pay
deal worth four percent in each of the
next two years was discussed but never
put on the table the employers the
state-owned network Rail and the rail
delivery group said progress had been
made but acknowledged ministers will
have the finals say we need to make sure
that there is a a pay deal that will
work for our staff and our colleagues
across the industry we need to make sure
that there's a set of reforms that the
rmt and other trade unions are
comfortable with implementing and we
need to make sure that we're doing that
without saying taking any more money
from the taxpayer than than is fair the
December strike dates will have an
economic impact hitting retail and
hospitality card over a key trading
weekend while commuters will face
inconvenience they're not on a bad wage
most of them particularly train drivers
so I think they're way way out of order
I don't blame them whatsoever just like
I don't blame the nurses or the postal
workers around but I blame the
government for the mess that we're in
these latest strikes are part of a
winter wave of industrial action Royal
Mail workers and nurses plan strike
action before the end of the year and
they share a common theme these are
workers demanding wages that keep up
with soaring inflation in a cost of
living crisis from employers and a
government so they just can't afford to
pay unions are scheduled to meet the new
transport secretary Mark Harper on
Thursday a meeting that may determine
whether the strikes go ahead Paul Kelso
Sky News in Birmingham